[Music]
what did you see
as you watched my reps and
one of you said the ikea adhesion that
is bringing them
forward that brings ukit forward
and i asked what visual cues or
elements led you to that
observation and you said
um that they came forward past
you and i asked the counter question how
do you know
that it's not just uke going past
of me bringing them past me one of you
said well they
going around you and i said well how do
you know that it's not
uk going around
instead of me bringing them around
and then one of you said
because there's a kind of umph almost as
if it's
unexpected and who
and where did you observe and by what
means
did this unexpected this
unexpectedness become visual
answer where anyone
i'm uk trying to catch up with this step
with this stuff okay so easy to pull
them
because they're playing catch-up means i
pulled them
is it a pull did they look like they're
being pulled
you're shaking your head no you need to
verbalize
so no so is ketchup the right word
okay so you see that their balance
it doesn't look like entirely under
their control
and they're trying to regain it okay
um i think you're on to something there
okay unless let's ask that okay
what what did you feel as
in this moment that they're trying to
give words to what they
saw particularly on one rep
i got hung up on my hakama and there was
a
i was i was going to continue
regardless of if i was
even able to move my feet or knees how i
wanted to
i got stuck and i was still gonna be
still going to go forward okay all right
i would say that's a pretty accurate
observation i think most people
think that the uke is just going past
and they start going why they can't see
how
it's not up to ukit the naga is doing it
okay and i want to introduce a concept
to you
in kihon there is a beginner phase you
must pass through in kihon
where you have to learn the ritual steps
and uke has to learn the ritual steps
um but the danger of staying there is
that
it's a dead form okay you're learning a
dead thing
and one way of bringing life into your
kihon
is that every uke
um will
because the human mind works like this
set
up some sort of dichotomous relationship
to what is happening
to them and by that
they manifest a
preference in terms of time and space
you should be able to feel that
construct
and that preference as nagin
okay and now what you want to do to make
your form alive
is i know where you wanted to stop do
you see
and now i use my internal aspects
to figure out how do i change that
desire
into my preference okay do you get it so
if i go like this and he stops there and
then i go around him this is a dead
floor
you see and he gets up there and then i
go around him that's the dead
but in every one of his he wants to stop
there
and i'm going to keep him going he keeps
me going he wants to stop there
nope
so each little preference that he has
brings its own new contention point to
reconcile and deconstruct okay
through my yin yang reconciliations
so the forbe is always he wants to stop
there oh no no no
no he wants to get up here
no no no no no we're going over there
you see that we'll use tristan
and everybody is different and every
rep is different so he wants to stop you
see
and he bends so far over so i feel that
and we're gonna keep him going
once you get up there no no no
what you'll feel is the new case it gets
very tiring
because nothing is where you wanted it
to be
your hair is breath change on now
so the form is very alive
you see and all those are little micro
moments where you're doing guaza
and the form becomes alive so since
what they want what they're willing to
do
and deconstruct that they're doing what
you're doing
okay
so uh gu is not antithetical to keyhole
dude it changes because how my mind
changes okay
how my hard mind changes okay so
as as you set up i i feel what you want
that's what you want right there
yeah that's what you want and you want
to go like this
then you get up and then i go
the reason it is spontaneous is because
i have to take your desire
deconstruct it and end up back in the
form
okay and so that is why kihon is not
antithetical to
you kihon creates a possibility for g
okay so i have to still find it no
no no no no no no no no
still find the form
[Music]
oh
what happens when you do this is your
line of gravity is going to be
in a state of position so see right here
it's inside your basic supply i go like
this
[Music]
you tilt it but it's inside your base
you come up it's inside
you think resist oh no
but when i'm doing this other thing
watch your lighting dropping
[Music]
here
okay don't let them have their balance
hey
so
now you're going to the front
they stayed still
keep that arm strong
throwing arms strong whether it's used
or not
back boom don't go back to the front
[Music]
so
this sense of aliveness doesn't have to
always be with an extending of what's
going on
i can't breathe with a short bean of
mustard
[Music]
so in this version i use this hand
this hand feeling the throwing hand
not just the backhand
someone might want to go all the way
through
how are you going to go buddy
so short technique
okay
you